puis saison qui abrité une quarantaine
d'immigrants chinois mais pas vraiment
c'est la plus grande fraude en matière
d'immigration de l'histoire du canada a
inscrit des centaines d'immigrants qui
ont eu recours à un fraudeur font
maintenant face à l'expulsion du canada
sommes pris tellement dossier avant
qu'on s'en rende compte c'est vraiment
un problème avec le système
on se transporte maintenant à vancouver
en 2012
ce jour là des agents fédéraux
perquisitionnent les bureaux d'un
consultant en immigration
parce qu'ils sont sur la piste d'une
fraude d'une ampleur inouïe
les consultants créer des vie fictive
pour ces gens il fournissait de fausses
adresses et de faux documents et
frédéric zajac vont nous raconter
comment l'un des fraudeurs à
l'immigration les plus prolifiques a été
démasqué et pourquoi d'autres prêts
passés à travers les mailles du filet
[Musique]
edmonton chaque année la capitale
albertaine accueille des milliers
d'émigrants mais en 2010 une résidence
unifamiliale attire l'attention d'agents
du ministère de l'immigration
cette maison semble bien populaire
auprès d'immigrants chinois un peu trop
même
les agents découvrent que pendant une
période de huit mois plus de 40
immigrants chinois nouvellement arrivés
au canada ont déclaré y vivre les agents
observent le même phénomène dans
d'autres résidences à calgary à edmonton
et à richmond en colombie britannique
de nombreuses adresses apparaissait à
répétition 20 30 voire 114 personnes
différentes
utiliser ces adresses c'était évidemment
et rend une adresse à calgary avait été
utilisé plus de 60 fois les agents
d'immigration réfugiés citoyenneté
canada ont alors envoyé la sphère l'
agence des services frontaliers pour
faire enquête
et ce n'est là que la pointe de
l'iceberg les agents ne se doutent pas
qu'ils sont sur le point de découvrir la
plus grande fraude à l'immigration de
l'histoire canadienne intercepté à
l'aéroport de vancouver
un de ces immigrants avoue avoir passé
seulement dix jours à calgary
il dit avoir résidé chez un ami mais un
ami dont il ne se souvient plus du nom
[Musique]
une immigrante dont l'adresse au dossier
est à edmonton concède qu'elle n'a
jamais vécu dans la capitale albertaine
elle est même incapable de reconnaître
le nom de la province
[Musique]
les enquêteurs découvrent que tous ces
immigrants ont un point en commun ils
ont retenu les services d'un conseiller
en immigration de la région de vancouver
jo noire surnomée sunny wong originaires
de chine
sunny wong fondent à vancouver en 2001
nukem un cabinet de consultation en
immigration
il avait les bureaux d'un centre de
vancouver qui ressemblaient à des
bureaux de consultants ils avaient des
secrétaires y avait les numéros ils
s'étaient pas quelqu'un qui se cachait
ce n'était pas quelqu'un qui agissait
comme un criminel
sunny wong s'enregistrent en bonne et
due forme auprès de la société
canadienne des consultants en
immigration
lord qui régit la profession à l'époque
mais en 2006 il ne renouvelle pas son
adhésion
il devient alors ce qu'on appelle un
consultant enfants tombent qu'ils
n'étaient pas autorisés à offrir ce
genre de service il n'était même pas un
consultant en immigration accrédités et
encore moins un consultant en
immigration comme étant de la fraude
pourtant le cabinet s'annonce
ouvertement dans les médias chinois de
vancouver ces publicités promettent des
solutions pour les cas problématiques
comme les immigrants n'ayant pas vécu
suffisamment longtemps au canada pour
maintenir le statut de résident
permanent pour conserver votre statut de
résident permanent au canada
vous devez y vivre ou moins 2 ans sur
cinq la plupart des clients de monsieur
wang ne respectait pas ces règles
la plupart des fraudes en matière
d'immigration sont généralement associés
aux personnes qui se faufile dans le
pays
mais ces riches d'immigrants cherche
plutôt à quitter le canada
le journaliste y et niang le
correspondant rancourt et roi du
quotidien sauf china morning post publié
depuis hong kong
il ya ce terme chinois i mean jeanne qui
signifie prison de l'immigration ce
concept est très bien connu parce que
beaucoup d'immigrants ici au canada ne
veulent pas nécessairement y être à
court terme
vous avez un emploi une famille et des
entreprises à gérer en chine grâce aux
adresses frauduleuses les clientes sunny
wong de l'impression d'habiter au canada
alors qu'ils sont plutôt en chine mais à
chaque fois qu'ils retournent dans leur
pays d'origine
les timbres apposés sur leur passeport
laisse des traces de leur long séjour à
l'étranger sony wang a prévu une combine
en modifiant les timbres sur les
passeports chinois de ses clients les
passeports étaient envoyés à l'une des
entreprises de monsieur wang en chine et
des timbres frauduleux était apposée
dans ces passeports
ce sont des timbres d'entrée et de
sortie frauduleux
so on voit qu'ici le timbre à dos et
ticket date d'arrivée en chine le 3 et à
droite le 01 échangé à 0,5 ce qui
signifie que la date d'entrée maintenant
le 3 mai cet exemple montre qu'ils ont
donné l'apparence d'être au canada
plutôt qu'à l'extérieur du pays
plusieurs clientes sony one vivent
toujours en chine quand vient le temps
de renouveler leur carte de résident
permanent
dans bien des cas ils sont convoqués à
une entrevue au canada et doivent
ramasser leurs nouvelles cartes en
personne
sony wang a tout prévu
ses clients prennent un vol de chine
vers seattle aux états unis puis
traversent la frontière canadienne en
voiture car il est rare que des timbres
d'entrées soit apposée aux frontières
terrestres
les clients prennent ensuite un vol vers
edmonton ou calgary où des complices les
reçoivent à l'aéroport ils leur font
faire une tournée rapide du quartier où
se trouve l'adresse frauduleuses les
clients peuvent ainsi mieux répondre à
d'éventuelles questions des autorités
ça couvre est des choses comme les
écoles fréquentées par les enfants
la description de leur quartier et une
idée générale de la vie d'un canadien
donc des directives et des conseils très
exhaustif lors été prodigués
dans ce courriel sony wang indique un
client qui n'aura pas besoin comprendre
des questions lors de l'entrevue
car toutes les réponses sont fournis en
traduction par la complice le client
peut répondre n'importe quoi en chinois
ce qui est dit n'a pas l'importance à
d'autres clients sony one offre un
stratagème de fou emploi pour leur
permettre de vivre en chine tout en
conservant leur statut de résident
permanent
si on travaille outre-mer pour une
compagnie canadienne sa croûte comme du
temps au canada
alors ce que nous kahn faisait c'est
qu'ils avaient leurs compagnes et oxford
royaume une dynastie han avaient toutes
une liste et il avait d activité fictive
enchaîne par l'on pouvait travailler
pour une compagnie canadienne en chine
aide les clients versé des fonds à
monsieur wang et à ses entreprises
d'harmonie weston sa taxe cet argent
était ensuite redistribués aux clients
sous forme de chèque de paie monsieur
wang et primes et des talons de paye et
à la fin de l'année il fournissait un
vrai feuillet d'impôt t4 indiquant que
ses clients avaient travaillé pour ces
sociétés pendant une période donnée
c'est ce stratagème qui a utilisé
zhaojin ni une millionnaire qui est
entré au canada grâce au programme
québécois des immigrants investisseurs
et la simuler être à l'emploi de niocan
afin de pouvoir renouveler sa résidence
permanente
même si en réalité elle habitait
toujours en chine zhao jing lee a obtenu
ce faux emplois avec new cannes en
réalité elle n'y a jamais travaillé
mais elle a reçu des talons paye ce qui
la rendait éligible au crédit d'impôt
pour les travailleurs à faible revenu et
elle les a réclamés là pendant des
années sony wang fait des affaires d'or
il accumule 10 millions de dollars grâce
à ses services auprès d'une clientèle
généralement fortunés avec les frais que
sans les wang demandait pour des
demandes frauduleuses
c'était des personnes qui avaient les
moyens le jeu de cfc frais commencé dans
les dents les huit dix mille et ça
c'était lille le début par rapport aux
fraudes
mais les frais pouvaient monter beaucoup
plus haut mais en 2011 la panique
s'installe au sein de son équipe
une employée laverty par courriel les
autorités ont découvert des numéros de
téléphone frauduleuses liées à 29
clients
ce n'est pas un enjeu mineur écrit t
elle car calgary enquête sérieusement
cette affaire dans sa réponse ce nîmois
ne s'en préoccuper que par la perte
financière qu'il va subir
cet incident nous apporte de très
grosses pertes
tout a explosé d'un coup nous devons
abandonner toutes les adresses et
numéros de téléphone utilisé
présentement il faut tout réorganiser
nous devrons probablement sacrifier de
nombreux clients
[Musique]
loin de fermer boutique sony wang
poursuit ses activités
promettant de trouver de nouvelles
adresses bidon en saskatchewan au
manitoba et même au québec
ils poussent elles émettent ils
poussaient les démettre et puis vers la
fin c'était vraiment une opération
carrément criminel
[Musique]
au cours des étés suivants en 2012
l'étau se resserre se dit wang fait
maintenant l'objet d'une opération de
surveillance
[Musique]
puis le 17 octobre 2012
l' agence des services frontaliers
frappe elle effectué des perquisitions
au bureau de new cannes et à la
résidence du fraudeur nous avons saisi
plus de 90 boîte remplie de documents et
18 ordinateurs contenant 2 téraoctets
d'information il ya donc énormément de
preuves qui doit être examinée analyser
et répertoriés et l or les enquêteurs se
rendent compte de l'ampleur sans
précédent des activités de sony mois
nous avons rapidement mis la main sur
des listes de clients
nous nous sommes immédiatement rendu
compte qu'il y avait des centaines et
des centaines de clients nous avons
également saisi des centaines de
passeport notre analyse a démontré que
ces passeports contenait d'éteindre
d'entrée et de sortie fraude yeux
par la suite les enquêteurs obtiennent
18000 courriel en chinois
ils amorcent un travail de traduction et
d' analyse colossal
deux ans plus tard en octobre 2014 les
enquêteurs de l'agencé des services
frontaliers se rendent à nouveau aux
bureaux de sony wang mais cette fois ci
pour procéder à son arrestation
quand nous sommes arrivés nous l'avons
pris en flagrant délit il s'est avancé
pour venir à la rencontre de nos agents
et avaient en main des copies de passe
pour modifier et une demande de
passeport
nous l'avons pincer alors qu'il
poursuivait les activités auxquelles
nous soupçonnions qui se livrait deux
ans auparavant sonné wagne libéré avec
de strictes conditions il lui est
interdit d'exploiter une entreprise ou
d'être en possession de formulaires
d'immigration pourtant dans les mois qui
suivent les autorités découvrent qu'il
continue ses activités en voyant même
notre formulaire frauduleux pour un
client il est à nouveau arrêté puis
incarcéré
sony wang plaide coupable à 15 chefs
d'accusation de fraude et d'évasion
fiscale il est condamné à plus de 900
mille dollars d'amendé et à 7 en prison
c'était une peine très importante est
l'une des plus longues que nous ayons
jamais vue au canada pour un stratagème
de fraude à l'immigration
n'importe qui qui travaillent dans
l'industrie c'est qu'il ya des personnes
qui font ce genre de choses en
particulier d'art est d'arriver au point
où il en était et que sam pris tellement
de dossiers avant qu'on s'en rende
compte c'est vraiment une indication de
problèmes avec le système d'immigration
des centaines de clients de sony one
font face à l'expulsion du canada
à la suite de notre enquête dans un
instant
[Musique]
à vancouver après l'arrestation et la
condamnation du consultants fantômes
sony one
la tâche est loin d'être terminée pour
l' agence des services frontaliers ses
clients aussi doivent répondre de leurs
actes
woodside nous avons identifié plus de
1600 personnes
nous avons enquêté sur chacune d'elles
afin de déterminer si elle avait fait
des fausses déclarations aux autorités
gouvernementales chose chaque semaine
des clients de sony wang sont appelés à
comparaître devant la commission de
l'immigration et du statut de réfugié
ils vont face à un renvoi du pays pour
avoir fait de fausses déclarations aux
autorités
normalement les caméras ne sont pas
permises ici pour obtenir cet accès nous
sommes engagés à brouiller l'image du
représentant du gouvernement canadien et
à ne pas identifier
l'immigrant encore aux nous la
surmonterons madame bing madame bing
admet avoir erré en ayant suivi les
conseils de sony one
mais elle espère obtenir la clémence du
commissaire grecque constantino car elle
sait depuis établi au canada en 2009
madame bing voulait obtenir la
citoyenneté canadienne
mais elle n'avait pas vécu au canada
suffisamment longtemps pour être
éligible pour contourner les règles elle
a retenu les services de sony one et lui
a versé neuf mille dollars
alors on voit toute une gamme dans les
1600 personnes du niveau d'implication
dans la fraude
l'avocat vancouvérois peter edman a
représenté des clients de sony wang
appelé à comparaître devant la
commission de l'immigration pour moi
j'ai vu une grande étendue de clients il
y avait certains clients qui comprenait
pas vraiment ce qui se passait
je pensais qu il faisait confiance à
monsieur wang est à l'autre bout qui
avait les personnes il savait exactement
ce qui se passe
il était très engagé dans la fraude il
était il avait été personnellement à
migration raconté de fausses histoires
madame bing dit que sony wang lui a fait
signer un formulaire où elle affirmé
avoir vécu à calgary pendant deux ans et
demi en réalité elle n'y avait habité
que pendant deux mois puis elle était
retournée vivre en chine
elle dit que sony one l'a incité à
mentir aux autorités canadiennes
s'il était questionné quant à ces
absences du canada
en mai 2011 elle et sa fille ont cru
qu'ils allaient assister à leur
cérémonie de citoyenneté
mais une fois sur place madame bing
s'est plutôt fait questionné au sujet de
timbres douteux dans son passeport de dh
qui coince branding a demandé à sony
wang de retirer sa demande de
citoyenneté et de la rembourser
l'avocat de madame bing soutient que sa
cliente était une victime de sony les
avocats des clients de sony wang dirais
qu'il s'agit de victimes mais dans
l'ensemble il s'agit de participants
consentants je pense que la plupart
d'entre eux savaient ce qu'il faisait
ils savaient qu'ils essayaient de flouer
système en fin de compte
le commissaire a rejeté l'appel de
madame bing dans sa décision
gray constantine ont écrit qu'elle
n'était pas une victime naïve innocente
qu'elle a participé de plein gré à une
manoeuvre frauduleuse et que son seul
regret c'est de s'être fait prendre ce
qu'ils vont devant la section d'appel
c'est la majorité vont perdre d'après ce
qu'on voit jusqu'à date
il ya peu de dossiers que l' agence a
décidé poursuivre ou la section d'appel
est prête à faire des exceptions
jusqu'à maintenant près de 1100 clients
de sony one font face à l'expulsion du
canada où ont déjà quitté le pays
nous nous rendons à richmond en banlieue
de vancouver à la recherche du cerveau
derrière toute l'opération sony wang a
obtenu une libération conditionnelle
après avoir passé deux ans en prison
aucune réponse à la porte de sa
résidence
le cas de sony one est un grand coup de
filet pour l' agence des services
frontaliers mais en raison de ses
ressources limitées
lagence d'y concentrer ses efforts dans
quête sur les cas de fraude massive
[Musique]
ils ont mis énormément de ressources
dans ces dossiers là ça veut dire qu'il
y en a beaucoup d'autres qu'on n'a pas
poursuivi
alors c'est vraiment une question de
choisir et de d'essayer de voir où
mettre les ressources les fraudeurs de
moindre envergure peuvent agir en toute
impunité selon directeur de
l'association des conseillers
professionnels en immigration
malheureusement ils sont pas trompés par
le système
présentement tout ce qu'ils font ces
transactions en immigration illégale
avec un nombre de cas minimes se sentent
protégés parce qu'ils savent que l'
agence frontalières ne viendra pas
les poursuivre il existe un organisme de
réglementation régissant les consultants
en immigration au canada mais il n'a
aucun pouvoir de contrainte sur ceux qui
ne sont pas enregistrés comme sony
moines
c'est une des raisons pourquoi monsieur
wang était capable après avoir délaissé
l'ordre professionnel de contigné tout
seul en étant non réglementée il est
plus autoriser de représenter par contre
il l'a fait parce que l'autre
professionnel
selon la loi actuelle a un rôle qui se
termine au moment où le membre n'est
plus membre
[Musique]
nous sommes retournés à la résidence de
sony warner richman pour tenter une
dernière fois de lui parler
un véhicule sort se limite au volant
sarr et de raffinement
peu de temps après pendant que nous
tournons des images de sa résidence
depuis la rue sony one revient et
appelle la police pour porter plainte et
nous passons cellulaire avec au bout du
fil une policière qui n'a aucune idée de
son passé criminel
les policiers ne voient aucune raison
d'intervenir puisque notre présence sur
un lieu public n'en feront pas la loi
[Applaudissements]
quand vous avez quelqu'un comme ça ni
wang qui crée une entreprise dont le
modèle est de satisfaire les gens qui
enfreignent les règles
vous savez que vous avez un problème il
a gagné 10 millions de dollars grâce à
ce stratagème
il a eu des milliers de clients et la
leçon à en tirer c'est qu'il ya un très
gros problème avec les immigrants
millionnaire
[Musique]